[Música]
hola soy sandro calderón castillo actor
y comunicador audiovisual
en la primera cuarentena es un
cortometraje llamado isabel solo con mi
celular con mis manos y con todo mi
cuerpo mente y corazón
cuando digo solo y con mis manos
no solamente me refiero a que hice un
cortometraje en términos de producción y
realización
sino que diseñé un cuerpo si hice una
muñeca de tamaño natural que sería la
actriz de mi cortometraje
porque una muñeca
porque crear un cuerpo con qué recursos
como cuáles fueron mis motivaciones que
había detrás
siempre hay algo detrás
de niño fui bastante hiperactivo así
como creativo me gustaba meterme en
problemas pero sobre todo me encantaba
buscar soluciones
recuerdo que mis padres y mis hermanos
mayores me regalaban estos juguetitos de
laberintos y dificultad donde puedes
pasarte horas y horas resolviendo mi
madre tejía y me acuerdo cuando se hacía
un gran nudo toda la madeja yo era el
hijo voluntario que se encargaba de
desenredar
después me acuerdo que lo hacía a
propósito
luego me acercaría a talleres de arte
cultura música baile teatro y hasta
kárate
con el fin de desarrollar mi creatividad
pero
a los cinco años
uno de mis primeros recuerdos
conscientes
fuera conocer a mi madre enferma
casi
casi falleciendo
la desahuciaron cuando yo tenía apenas 6
años
pero ella se resistía a morir
es así como toda mi familia
de alguna manera aprendimos a convivir
con la muerte
usando fuerza determinación y mucho amor
para mantenernos a salvo en todos los
sentidos si
cuerpo cabeza y corazón
comenzaron a ser parte de esta historia
y creo que ahí empezó todo
antes de morir
mi madre tuvo muchas recaídas en su
salud
pero también victorias
victoria se llamaba a ella
ella fue la que más impulso mi carrera
de actor fue mi fan número 1 ella apoyó
todos los proyectos de gestión teatral
tanto así que la casa se volvió una
especie de centro de creación centro
cultural de enseñanza tertulias y más
ella sabía lo difícil que sería ser
artista a finales de los 80s por eso
pidió que estudiara otra profesión más
por ella me hice comunicador audiovisual
y créanme me está dando muchas
satisfacciones
como compartir con ustedes esta historia
mi historia
ella ha partido de este mundo terrenal
cuando yo apenas empezaba a ser un
jovencito
cuando acababa mi profesión sí
pero muchas promesas de mi parte
quedaron en el aire
sin concretar
de pronto luego de un viaje de 30 años
que me da la vida con cosas buenas y
cosas malas
aterrizó aquí en el presente 2020 el año
pasado con contratos firmados para todo
el año proyectos viajes hasta un nuevo
amor
y llega a la cuarentena
la noticia me sorprendió con menos de 20
dólares en el bolsillo cero ahorros en
el banco y pocos víveres en la despensa
yo dije esto no va a durar mucho
solamente es una medida preventiva nada
más va a pasar rápido en todo caso los
de mi generación ya hemos pasado por
cosas terribles
resistiré como dice la canción me dije
debo confesar que lo que más me dolió de
la cuarentena
no fue la pérdida del trabajo los
proyectos o exponerme un virus mortal o
incluso estar separado de la gente que
más amo no
fue no poder bailar en pareja
por eso las dos primeras semanas recurrí
a mi alter ego sal sandro un dj que
llevaba música por transmisiones en vivo
a través de las redes sociales tenía mi
gente un día me atrevo a bailar frente a
la cámara ojo para ese tiempo el tic tac
no era muy conocido para esto ya venía
viendo en las redes sociales el efecto
que estaba causando la cuarentena en la
gente se acuerdan de los vídeos de
personas que bailaban frente al espejo
hoy usando el reflejo como si fuera una
pareja de baile o agarrar incluso una
silla colocarle una prenda y también
fingir que estaba bailando con alguien
simplemente eso eran expresiones de la
necesidad de contacto de creer estar
acompañados
nosotros fuimos encerrados sino también
separados aislados
cancelados de alguna forma para proteger
nuestra salud
la ausencia del contacto físico y sus
estragos se hacían cada vez mayor y es
ahí cuando decido recurrir a una vieja
creación mía y digo vieja porque ya la
había usado antes en obras de teatro
y comencé a crear un cuerpo
una muñeca de tamaño natural para bailar
yo digo cómo construir una muñeca de
tamaño natural al estilo de la película
de luis garcía berlanga
por ahí recordé que tenía unas medias
panties y zapatos de mi enamorada sólo
eso entonces agarré también ropa mía
unos guantes sacrifiqué unas cuantas
almohadas para el relleno de las
rodilleras del patinaje y comencé a
armar un cuerpo el cuerpo de esa muñeca
fueron muchos días de manera
inconsciente donde me estaba sumergiendo
en el proceso creativo que me llevaría a
crear una película
invocar y relacionarme seguramente con
el ser que más he amado durante toda mi
vida
victoria mi madre
ya con el cuerpo de la muñeca armado
reposando sobre mi mueble de habitación
desperté con una idea fija
miré al cielo de mi habitación e imaginé
qué pasaría si alguien me estuviera
mirando o escuchando desde arriba desde
el cielo raso escondido
creo que la cuarentena ya me está
empezando a hacer efecto
me parece cuidadosamente sobre la cama
miré el techo largo rato
y se me vino la idea de crear una
historia única
un cortometraje que más adelante
llamaría y saber
confieso que el proceso para hacer esta
película no fue nada ortodoxo no solo
tenía una idea pero no un guión solo
tenía mi celular y nada más es así como
un arte colectivo como es el cine se
convirtió en un proyecto bastante
personal único
literal en el sentido de la palabra sólo
yo actor sólo yo director técnico
creador solo yo y mi necesidad de contar
de evocar vida concretar resolver cosas
pendientes
acaso conmigo
acaso con mi madre
de pronto con el poco dinero que llegaba
compraba también algunos accesorios para
la producción de mi película luego mi
enamorada demandó uno de sus vestidos
con sus accesorios en taxi entonces era
hora de crear lo que para mí sería algo
muy importante
la cabeza de la muñeca cuerpo
cabeza otro largo proceso las primeras
versiones de la cabeza fueron realmente
espantosas pero creativas
por ejemplo el cabello de isabel está
compuesta por estas cintas tape no las
cintas tape pasando por pablo milanés
silvio rodríguez soda estéreo llegando a
black sabbath led zeppelin o sea que su
cabellera es bastante nueva trova
metalera y ondulante además como como lo
era mi madre
de hecho la creación de la cabeza me
tomó muchas noches y madrugadas enteras
fue importante este proceso porque
estaba creando y completando la
identidad pensante de la muñeca de ese
ser de esa inspiración para contar luego
una historia
ya ha empezado a humanizarla
una vez que acabe la cabeza a la tercera
versión la unidad el cuerpo y ya te
estaba lista mi creación
no era un ser cualquiera era mi actriz
principal si a partir de ahí comencé a
pensar en la historia de manera profunda
y completa
el cuento de la película es bastante
sencillo
un hombre maduro que se queda solo en su
departamento para enfrentar la
cuarentena sin recursos y aislado
completamente en términos de
comunicaciones un día descubre que en el
cielorraso de su habitación hay una
maleta escondida
la curiosidad es grande y decide sacarla
encontrando dentro elementos que parecen
ser de un titiritero
máscaras de teatro de las cámaras
fotográficas y un enorme paquete
cubierto por una tela
la desenvuelve y descubre la cabeza de
una muñeca de trapo unido a un palo
pasan los días que
decide de alguna manera acompañarse
de este títere
un día escuchando uno de los tantos
mensajes presidenciales que hablaba de
la familia y enfrentar la crisis en
unión familiar
conecta con la palabra familia
y decide ir un almacén
traer ropa de mujer que no sabemos de
quién era almohadas maderas y más y
decidir
y decide darle un cuerpo y darle un
cuerpo a esa muñeca
luego sigue conectando una vez que su
creación ya está hecha y decide
acompañarse de lee cuentos que tocan la
flauta
escuchan música ven televisión juegan
ajedrez
se acompaña
una noche descubres un hombre dentro de
un corazón de plástico isabel
elisabeth la muñeca ya no es más una
muñeca ahora es un ser con nombre con
identidad solo lo que se nombra existe
de pronto otro día se prepara para una
gran noche especial se corta el cabello
se afeita se baña se prepara para una
cena prepara una cena con lo poco que
tiene viste isabel con un traje rojo y
le coloca joyas acaso joyas de un
antiguo amor
a caso de su madre toman vino bailan
valses no sabemos qué va a ocurrir
tal vez el protagonista ha descendido a
lo más profundo de su locura
hasta aquí podemos preguntarnos si todo
lo cura es mala
si es mejor eso al estado consciente
depredador
de pronto la contempla a largo rato
mira profundamente en sus ojos toca sus
pechos
y le coloca el corazón donde encontró su
nombre
entra en un profundo sueño
al despertar a la mañana siguiente
la muñeca no está pero si la maleta y
los otros objetos
el protagonista se levanta busca
brevemente con la mirada en su
habitación pero sobre todo en sus
recuerdos en sus sueños
acaso en toda su vida
finalmente con tranquilidad liberadora
va hacia la ventana de su habitación
abre las cortinas dejándolo entrar al
sol
a la nueva oportunidad
hasta aquí seguro se preguntarán qué
tiene que ver todo esto con mi madre
en todo mi proceso creativo
ella estuvo presente de manera
inconsciente la misma relación del
protagonista con isabel es la relación
que quise tener con mi madre a lo largo
de estos años de ausencia y se hizo real
en muchas escenas y acciones de la
película la imagen de una compañera que
impulsó el protagonista a ser mejor a
sentirse acompañado a no enloquecer tal
vez a tocar lo más profundo de su
subconsciente
a sacar recuerdos a liberar muchas cosas
guardadas sin concretar
le debía a mi madre una función de
teatro
un baile la mejor cena leerle más libros
cantarle llevarla de paseo
y terminé haciéndolo todo en una
película para ella
esta historia ha sido contada con pocos
recursos técnicos y económicos
la mayoría creados por mí como un riel
eso es por donde pasa en la cámara
creado con una regleta de drywall usando
uno de mis patines también
el 4 metraje está participando en
concursos dentro y fuera del país
pero sobre todo está tocando corazones
de muchas personas esto me ha permitido
crear y concretar una obra audiovisual
especial en un momento difícil
algo que venía presionando hace mucho
tiempo la vida es sabia
no hice otros cortometrajes antes porque
según yo no tenía el presupuesto no
tenía el equipo técnico y humano
pero la vida me encerró en la cuarentena
solo con mi celular y me dijo es hora de
contar una historia especial que marcará
tu vida y tal vez la de mucha gente
gracias a isabel ya victoria estoy aquí
contando parte de mi vida compartiendo
con ustedes
y en centros educativos centro de
producción con profesionales de la salud
mental
con esta película puede invocar crear
concretar
y enfrentando la crisis
de la mejor manera porque todo acto de
creación
es un acto de amor con cuerpo mente y
corazón
gracias